since you're so busy with the hard
engineering challenges
of everything that's involved
are you still able to marvel at the
magic of it all of space travel
of every time the rocket goes up
especially when it's accrued mission or
you're just so overwhelmed
with all the challenges that you have to
solve
and actually sort of to add to that
the reason i wanted to ask this question
of may 30th it's it's been some time so
you can look back and think about the
impact already it's already at the time
it was an engineering problem maybe
now it's becoming a historic moment like
it's a moment that
how many moments will be remembered
about the 21st century to me
that or something like that maybe
inspiration for one of those would be
remembered as the early steps of a new
age of uh space exploration
yeah i mean during the launches itself
so i mean i think i think maybe some
people know but a lot of people don't
know it's like i'm actually the chief
engineer of spacex so
um
the
you know i've signed off on pretty much
all the design decisions
um and
you know so if there's
something that goes wrong with that
vehicle it's it's fundamentally my fault
you know so
um
so i'm really just thinking
about all the things that like so so
when i see the rocket i see all the
things that could go wrong and the
things that could be better and
the same with the dragon spacecraft it's
like
other people say oh this is a
spacecraft or a rocket and that's this
looks really cool i'm like
i've i've like a readout of like this is
the these are these are the risks these
are the problems that's what i see
so it's
not what other people see when they see
the product you know
you